ja ich habe dich gesehen was denn
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es eine restpfanne aus dem
Ofen nämlich eine tex-mex-pfanne also so
ein bisschen Chili con Carne mäßig aber
nicht scharf denn auch wenn ich sehr
gerne scharf esse ist nicht jeder bei
uns in der Familie schon vor allem die
Kinder nicht so sehr deswegen kann man
ja danach gerne noch Chili-Soße oder
Chili Olivenöl drauf geben aber beim
Kochen lass es mittlerweile meistens weg
die Zutaten sind ganz überschaubar und
das ganze wird erst auf dem Herd
praktisch ein bisschen angebraten und
dann im Ofen überbacken das wird richtig
lecker das sage ich euch ich zeige euch
mal eben die Zutaten ihr könnt das ganze
mit Hackfleisch machen oder auch mit
veganem Hack machen dann ist das Ganze
nämlich sogar vegan dafür verwende ich
500 Gramm Hackfleisch vom Rind oder ihr
könnt auch veganes Hackfleisch nehmen
eine Zwiebel eine Knoblauchzehe etwas
Olivenöl 30 oder 40 g Tomatenmark eine
Dose Tomatenstücke das sind 400 Gramm
400g Fleischbrühe eine Dose Mais eine
Dose Kidneybohnen Salz und Pfeffer dann
habe ich hier noch die Kürze nämlich
Curry Kreuzkümmel und Paprika und 200
Gramm Reis ich habe jetzt hier eine
parboile entlangkornreis ihr könnt aber
gerne jede Reissorte nehmen die ihr
gerade da habt oder die ihr gerne mögt
zuerst gebe ich jetzt Olivenöl in meinen
Bräter und ich nehme jetzt hier den
gusseisenbräter denn der funktioniert
sowohl auf dem Herd als auch im Backofen
das heißt es ist sozusagen ein One Pot
Gericht
hier schön erhitzen
und in der Zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die Zwiebel und Knoblauchzehe
einwürfeln ich liebe es ja wenn ich
Gerichte habe die lecker sind die dann
aber auch noch einfach zuzubereiten sind
mit wenig Geschirr und ich weiß dass sie
das auch liebt also habe ich mir das so
rum überlegt und deswegen muss ich sagen
sind Gusseisen Produkte wirklich perfekt
denn ich kann hier anbraten und den Rest
im Ofen garen
dann brate ich das Hackfleisch hier an
schön krümelig braten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn Hackfleisch dann krümelig gebraten
ist kommen die Zwiebel und
Knoblauchwürfel dazu
die werden dann bislang mit gebraten 2-3
Minuten
damit sie schön anderes
ich hoffe ich sag später nicht hätte ich
bloß eine größere Schüssel genommen
das sieht super aus und jetzt kommt hier
das Tomatenmark dazu das sieht bei mir
immer ein bisschen komisch aus weil mein
Tomatenmark immer eingefroren ist und
eiswürfelbehältern aber so habe ich es
immer portioniert und immer schön auf
Lager weil ich meistens große Gläser
kaufen und die dann eben abholen dann
mit den Tomaten ablöschen
die Brühe dazu geben
ich lasse jetzt einmal kurz aufkochen
damit sich hier am Boden alles ablöst
was vielleicht so ein bisschen
angebrannt ist das habe ich den Herd
ausgeschaltet und kann das ganze würzen
mit Salz und Pfeffer und meinen drei
Gewürzen die ich vorbereitet habe
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt hier noch die drei
Zutaten nämlich Mais Kidneybohnen und
den Reis den habe ich bereits gewaschen
sollte man immer tun
[Musik]
alles schön einrühren
so sieht es jetzt aus bei mir passt die
Menge an Wasser denn ich habe eine
Dampfbackofen das heißt ich werde das
Gericht jetzt 22 Minuten Dampfgaren ich
zeige euch das auch gleich hier an der
Einstellung am Ofen ansonsten könnt ihr
aber auch etwa 400 Milliliter Meerwasser
dazugeben damit einfach der Reis genug
Flüssigkeit hat und mit dem Ofen eben
sogar das heißt ihr könnt es auch bei
ober Unterhitze Backen ihr könnt auch
bei Heißluft Backen ich schreibe euch
auch alles in die App oder in den Block
aber ich werde es jetzt Dampfgaren und
später schreibe ich noch ein bisschen
Käse und dann wird es erst im Ofen
überbacken
ist die große kennenlernen schon live
auf RTL ab 20:15 Uhr da werden wir
tanzen wir erfahren wer unsere
Tanzpartner sind also ich werde dann
erst gleich im Fernsehen erfahren wer
der Tanzpartner ist und ihr dürft gerne
am Freitag schon anrufen
da fliegt man noch keiner raus aus der
Show aber es ist so dass wenn am Freitag
wenn man da schon ganz viele Anrufe
bekommt hat man ein sicheres Ticket für
die Woche danach und wenn ihr möchtet
dass ich weiterkomme dann ruft gerne für
mich an und unterstützt mich ich freue
mich auf die Zeit ich war heute schon so
über emotional bisschen viele Gefühle
die Tage und ich bin sehr aufgeregt sind
einfach noch so viele Faktoren die ich
nicht beeinflussen kann
ich hoffe ihr begleitet mich durch diese
Zeit durch diese aufregende Zeit
ihr könnt hier immer auf Menü drücken
dann auf die assist Funktion und habt
hier beim Rädchen Beilagen und Gemüse
könnt dann auch Reis gehen und dann eure
Reissorte auswählen ich hatte jetzt hier
den Langkornreis und dann steht hier
nämlich direkt 22 Minuten
hier steht noch ein Tipp
wie viel Flüssigkeit dazu gegeben werden
muss und dann kann man das Ganze eben so
drin garen
jetzt ist der Ofen vorgeheizt
und ich kann das Gericht Dampfgaren und
später dann einfach bei der
Grillfunktion oder bei Ober-Unterhitze
schön mit dem Käse überbacken das war
schon oh da passt ein Salat perfekt dazu
ich muss jetzt hier nichts mehr
einstellen denn das macht doof
[Musik]
so sieht das Gericht jetzt aus ich finde
es riecht hier drinnen wunderbar wir
werden jetzt gleich probieren
[Musik]
das sieht fantastisch aus
und es schmeckt fantastisch
ich mache mir dazu jetzt noch einen
Schmand oder Joghurt sehr wenig dazu
schmeckt aber auch so schon perfekt
und ich finde sogar es könnten jetzt
wird es verrückt Cranberries noch rein
oder zum Beispiel so kleine Rosinen denn
ich mag es tatsächlich ganz gerne wenn
bei sowas würzigem noch so ein bisschen
was Süßes dabei ist wobei er der Mais an
sich schon etwas süßliches hat aber ich
finde es super ich finde Ananas sogar
cool ich habe meine Türkei einen Ananas
Eis gegessen der war der Hammer mit
Mandeln und das schreibe ich mir gleich
auf das mache ich für euch Ananas Reis
mit Mandeln dazu mache ich vielleicht
ein Hähnchen das passt ganz gut oder nur
den anderen Reis ich habe Hunger das
heißt für euch ihr könnt das Rezept
gerne nachmachen ihr findet auf Sallys
blog.de und in meiner App natürlich ich
wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen
und bis zum nächsten Mal
ich bin froh ich mache gerade viele
Reisgerichte dann irgendwie habe ich
Reisgerichte in der Vergangenheit ein
bisschen vernachlässigt gell tschüss
ja ich habe dich gesehen was denn
[Musik]